the rocky inner planets of our solar
system are thought to have mostly
metallic cores a building block of
Planet formation but because the cores
are so difficult to reach scientists can
only speculate on their exact
composition and what stories they might
tell us about the origins of our planets
but that's about to
change Vehicles pitch down range this is
the first time NASA has ever sent a
mission to this type of world the mostly
metal World here's a look at a NASA
mission to the asteroid psyche what
scientists think is a metallic core from
a planet that never formed and how the
mission could tell us more about the
origins of planet
Earth more than 1 million asteroids have
been discovered in our solar system of
those Millions psyche was the 16th to be
discovered dating back to the mid 1800s
most asteroids are made of rock and ice
but scientists believe the psyche
asteroid named after the Greek goddess
of the soul is made of metal in the
earliest days of our solar system about
4.5 billion years ago there were a lot
of objects made of metal and rock and
Ice that were violently colliding
together some of them accreted to form
the cores and outer layers of our
planets like Earth and Mars the best
theory so far is that psyche is one of
the sort of exposed cores of these
planetesimals these planets that never
came to be but until the psyche
spacecraft arrives at the asteroid in
2029 scientists can't say for certain
that this is psyche's origin story even
though we don't know its origin and
Genesis with complete certainty the
value of a mission like this is
unprecedented a recent analysis by NASA
indicates that psyche is likely made of
a mixture of rock and metal with metal
composing between 30 to 60% of its
volume but why are scientists spending
more than $1 billion to study metal
the fact that it's possibly the exposed
core of one of these protoplanets is
significant because Earth formed from
the accretion of of many many
protoplanets and so psyche is one small
microcosm of a building block of what
came to make Earth Earth Earth's outer
core lies at a depth of over 1,800 miles
so far scientists have only drilled down
about 7 and 1 half of those Miles
because that's as far as our current
technology can take us
and because we can't travel back in time
to the earliest days of our solar system
and we can't right now delve into the
center of our own Planet psyche provides
this excellent proxy for trying to
better understand the evolution of our
planetary neighborhood to study the
asteroids composition the psyche
spacecraft made by maxar Technologies
and NASA's jet propulsion laboratory
will carry a payload of scientific
instruments the instruments will
determine if psyche has a magnetic field
study its chem chemical and mineral
composition and map out its topography
psyche is currently the only known place
in our solar system where scientists can
examine directly what may contain metal
from the core of a planet ismal NASA
seems to be in what some scientists call
the Golden Age of asteroids asteroids
and small bodies like comets were
ignored for a long time in lie of going
to the moon and trying to figure out how
to get to Mars and now I think NASA is
really putting its money where it's m is
in terms of exploring these types of
Worlds and while the most recent
asteroid related Mission brought back
samples from a different asteroid and
psyche isn't bringing back samples the
Rarity of this metallic world and what
we could learn from it really is what
gives this Mission
[Music]
value